because my producers hate me and they're
sadists
they are forcing me to watch a new ad
campaign from the national football
league i have assiduously avoided
watching
the nfl ever since they disrespected our
flag in our entire country they're
embarrassing me they're embarrassing
america can't say i watched it all that
much before then but occasionally every
now and now i don't do it so the
producers have locked me in this chair
it's like a torture chamber and they
want me to try to help them make sense
of the new inspire change campaign from
the nfl let me tell you about where i'm
from
where i'm from poverty is a crime
that's not true
if you look like me you're over policed
overcharged and over incarcerated nope i
was sentenced to die in prison for a 28
robbery for changes i don't believe that
nfl and alabama appleseed are fighting
to free victims of wrongful punishment
and excessive sentences
together justice inequality will belong
to everyone no matter where you're from
do you believe that i mean i don't
believe really any of the claims made in
that video but do you believe that a man
was sentenced to die in prison over a 28
robbery 28 robbery i wish you weren't a
liar i just don't think that's true i
think i think we're missing some details
obviously i don't i don't know this
man's name i don't know the nature of
his crime but i would be willing to bet
a lot of money that there is more to the
story than that that man took 28 dollars
from somebody i just wish you weren't a
liar don't you unless you really believe
as a lot of people on the left do that
america is just a vicious
cruel racist bigoted evil place i don't
think that a man was sentenced to die in
prison
for taking 28 dollars if this was a
death penalty state you'd be getting the
chair he's clearly not in prison right
now he's making this dumb commercial for
the national football league where i
live poverty is a crime
how
how is poverty a crime do you mean that
people who are poor
sometimes commit crimes because they're
poor committing a crime is a crime in
that case and very often i have to tell
you i know people pretend that they
commit crimes because they're so poor
there's a spate of robberies going on
right now in san francisco among other
places where people are walking off the
street and just robbing the string just
taking stuff and putting it in a trash
bag i don't think this is a man walking
into the bakery and taking a loaf of
bread to feed his children i think this
is degenerate criminal people going in
and breaking the law intentionally
because they're they're morally
twisted and because they'll get away
with it because the society is
encouraging this kind of depravity and i
think it's harmful for society obviously
it's harmful for the shop owners it's
harmful for all of us who don't want
crime on our streets but it's harmful
for the criminal because it is
encouraging criminals to go even further
down this path of destruction
poverty is a crime i don't think that's
true anywhere in the country black men
are over-incarcerated if you look like
me you're over-incarcerated what does
that mean over-incarcerated
we don't have an over-incarceration
problem in this country for black men or
white men or any other kind of men we
have an under-incarceration problem
because we have a lot of crime and crime
is shooting through the roof around our
country so by definition we are not
locking up enough criminals sometimes
you will hear that that people in this
country and black men in particular are
going to prison
for simple
marijuana possession apparently trivial
drug offenses just a little bit of wheat
man these are not even my pants these
are my friends fans that's not true
something like 97
of the inmates in prison are there not
for simple possession but for drug
trafficking and by the way even if you
look at the roughly three percent and in
at the federal level it's even less than
that it's 0.9 or so of federal inmates
who are in for possession offenses of
any kind by the way not just marijuana
but heroin and fentanyl and other
really poisonous substances the actual
people who just go to prison for
possession like as though there are cops
out hunting for pot smokers and for
black men in particular to throw them in
the can for smoking a joint it just
doesn't exist it's just completely made
up like everything else in this nfl ad
so what they're selling you is not
football
it's not
knowledge about the way that our
political system works they're just a
lot they're just peddling lies what
they're selling you is
hatred of america america bad america as
it was bad america as it is bad america
needs to fundamentally transform and so
you've got to be
the change and and the saddest part of
all of it well i suppose the saddest
part is that this is destructive toward
the common good and our society as a
whole
but only slightly less sad than that
still really really unfortunate is that
it's going to encourage people
to
continue along destructive behaviors
it's going to encourage criminals to say
the fact that i'm committing crime is
not my fault it's someone else's fault
it's going to encourage people who are
not trying to improve their lives to say
well it's not up to me to improve my
life someone else has to improve my life
for me the society needs to improve my
life it's just not fair i can never i
can never get ahead and it's going to
encourage americans to hate their own
country and hate their own countrymen
which is really going to harm their
communities and going to harm society
and actually that's that's already what
we're seeing happen around us
[Music]
[Music]